all right anthony
yeah anthony where'd you grow up where
are you from original uh my name is
anthony bernard i grew up in lancaster
pennsylvania about an hour outside of
philadelphia
what was your childhood like you had
both your parents
yeah the first three years was somewhat
normal um my mother took her life when i
was three years old in an overdose of
pills and uh
my father
um
just kind of turned an alcoholic
afterwards i lived with my grandparents
for a number of years after that
and uh
until pops remarried at about when i was
seven years old
um
kind of grew up as a black sheep my dad
and stepmother had uh
two two brothers after me uh two half
brothers and uh
yeah i guess it was somewhat
normal uh except maybe some emotional
you know distancing uh feeling not a
part of the family
but
you know what can i give you in high
school
um
kind of not friends with anyone in
particular uh didn't have much of like a
i didn't fit into anyone's sort of
category
um a generally good student but my
outlet was reading i had a i was kind of
a anti-social
um
child who
did a lot of reading when i found out i
could just escape into
books i was i was happy as a kid
good good student uh seemed promising a
pretty good well-behaved child up until
about 16 where uh
you know somebody introduced me to pot
and
i kind of felt like i belonged in a
category of
misfits
maybe around 16 i kind of kind of found
a small what i what i felt like was a
friend group
basically our common
commonality was a pot and drinking
and uh
after school you went where yeah um well
i it kind was by myself for a little
while
i just like the the little secret that i
had i could smoke a joint at night after
everyone but went to sleep i found
cigarettes and it was like my little
thing
that i had to look forward to and
i left home the day before my 18th
birthday i had a job i was working at
mcdonald's and i was enrolled to go to
college but uh
the day before my 18th birthday i packed
up all my stuff went to work and didn't
go go home i grew up in kind of an
emotionally somewhat physically abusive
childhood
didn't appreciate dad and stepmom
and uh
when i thought i was legally emancipated
i left
um
thought i'd be able to to figure out the
world by myself and
and i didn't
i was enrolled in college i lived on
campus but dropped out of
college and and didn't continue going to
classes for about four years
um
and it was just kind of four years worth
of partying uh experimental drugs and
drinking and so you stayed on campus but
you yeah i lived in a college apartment
um i had a full-time masonry job doing
stone stone masonry back east
and uh
yeah i just lived on campus and and
drank and partied like i was a college
student but didn't go to classes
found
heavier drugs than pot and alcohol
more club-like scene drugs
mdma and psychedelics and stuff you know
into music festivals
and uh advanced nowhere in terms of my
life just
you know existing and kind of kind of
existing to have fun or what i thought
was a good time
after a couple years uh i met a girl
and thought i'd go back to school for
and uh
re-enrolled in college made it about
three months before uh you know things
broke off with her and i dropped out
again and two twice out of college i'm
about 23 24 years old and i started
experimenting with heroin
that then friend group kind of moved on
and graduated high school and moved back
to their
their hometowns and i was kind of left
with
myself
um
and today you're in skid row today i'm
in skid row how long you been down here
um about four months um
this time around i'm
i'm originally from from pennsylvania
and philadelphia big cities are where i
find trouble it's easy to disappear and
accessibility even
the drugs and the lifestyle it's just
just like gets get trapped in big cities
is heroin still your drug today it is um
basically anything that that takes me
outside of myself but but heroin yeah is
a real efficient means to do in that
um
after several years worth of you know
drug use and institutions back east i
had the opportunity to come back out or
come out to california for a rehab
center
about three or four years ago i went
through that rehab center and i
got to experience about a year and a
half
worth of sobriety
um
probably the most productive and
and uh
best year and a half of my life and
i decided to go back east for a high
school sweetheart of mine that i had
reconnected with
we had a baby and
he's now two and a half years old and we
split up when he was four months old and
rather than
[Music]
take that on the chin and do the right
thing afterwards i took it hard and and
relapsed and
wasn't a present father i've not been a
present father to him in the last two
years
it's been rough i've watched
uh my son's mom move on with somebody
else she's now
due with some other man's
child and uh
in an attempt to clean back up i came
back out to california and have not been
able to plug in with the proper
resources and and just continued
the same thing i was doing out east out
here
and you're staying we're just in a tent
now or yeah yeah i'm homeless in l.a uh
i came out here i had a couple hundred
dollars uh i had a plan to get sober um
i've since lost my wallet lost my phone
don't have any money left don't have any
resources right
i just
i quickly depleted all the resources i
quickly lose everything i have when i'm
using
um how do you support yourself now
um lately it's it's
you know living off of residual uh
unemployment money and
um
just the random
hustles meet people
this and that
um
you know being a middleman somebody
looking for something go and help them
out and break it off and it's just
survival
uh
yeah what kind of emotions do you deal
with
um
how old are you
i'm 28 years old yeah um
you know when i'm using
not many which is this is why uh
why it has its appeal as soon as i've
made these attempts i get
you know and i'll get sober and i'll
have about three or four days worth of
sobriety before i start to get this
angst and i'll look at the wreckage of
the last 10 years and i know there's a
whole lot of shame
there's a lot of shame there's a whole
lot of fear that uh
i'm not going to be the father that i
always wanted to be that you know
there's there's a whole lot of shame
that
you know there's there's been a lot of
wreckage in the past people that i've
hurt and people that i love
and uh
rather than
then take that as motivation to make a
change and do the right thing it's it's
just a
catch-22 circle with a hurting myself
and hurting others and
being angry at myself and wanting to
escape myself that it's just a vicious
circle um
i think that there's there's an appeal
to the lifestyle of being homeless and
using drugs not only because i don't
have to think about myself or look at
myself or face and feel my emotions but
rather
when i'm focused on how i'm going to
sleep where i'm going to eat
and how i'm going to get high they seem
like three major crucial things to pour
all of my energy and attention into
uh and when i when i clean up i have
15 years worth of wreckage that i've got
to clean up before i could start making
headway and it's
it's just a
feeling of discouragement
um
you know fear shame and regret would be
a lot of the key emotions did you
suspect that maybe
you haven't fully dealt with your mom's
suicide when you were young um
you know i do believe there's a whole
lot of character traits that i have that
that are a result of that
relationship after relationship after
relationship with women in my life over
the last 15 years it comes with this
fear and this angst that they're gonna
leave
um that ultimately ends up pushing them
away
um
so yeah i do i feel like there's there's
there are some uh character traits of
mine that are
that are a result of her and her death
it's a heavy thing to deal with
um and process
yeah
i don't feel as though it's something
that's at the forefront of my mind all
the time but i i i've noticed in my
relations with others in the way that i
view the world then
yeah there are some uh
there are some ways that i i look at the
world
um what was your mom going through that
it
from my understanding she was just
depressed she had some major depressive
disorder um
and
you know i was i was kind of young but
the way that it was explained to me was
that she was just she just suffered from
extreme depression
what do you worry about now
um
right now it's so easy for me to take
a week and turn it into a month and a
month into six months into six months
into a year and like i'm at this point
where i'm i'm not getting
any younger my son's not getting any
younger and uh
i have this desire to to clean up and do
the right thing and it's
i just i don't see
a clear path as to how
um
and i guess my current fear is that this
is where i'm going to be when i'm 40
this is where i'm going to be when i'm
50. um
i've had so many
so many times over the last 15 years
where i've i've put down drugs and
alcohol and i've i've had this
confidence in
not promising family or anyone other
than myself that i'm going to do the
right thing next time and uh failing
myself again and again
and uh
there's just there's just a lack of
confidence that comes with that so
you know as many results as i can make
i'm just scared that this is this is the
a life that i was doomed to
um
you've tried to get clean i have and and
yeah with a lot of confidence like i've
said before and and then
but ultimately find myself
yeah like i said i can make a promise to
myself one day and be in a completely
different frame of mind three days later
where i just get
uh bombarded with the anxiety and the
and the fear and the shame and
everything and
and then i break the promise that i had
made to myself just a few days prior
um
and it's
yeah it's made for a frustrating
existence sure
what is your biggest regret um
my biggest regret right now is being
absent for the first two and a half
years of my son's life and uh
not being present to be a father to him
not only for him but for his
mother uh
heroin just makes it so difficult for
you to get your
get your life together
it makes it difficult for that but it
also makes it difficult for
for anything in my life to have any sort
of meaning
i could tell my grandparents and my uh
my son and my son's mother how much i
love them uh but my actions speak
differently
and uh that's the most difficult thing
is wanting to convey
the way that i feel inside towards them
and knowing that it falls on deaf ears
because they just look at the actions
rather than uh
yeah that's really going on i have an
integrity problem
i can i could love them to death but uh
i don't love myself enough to stick
around for them yeah drugs will do that
what do you think what do you think most
people don't understand about
about addiction
um
i think that they look at the action
rather than than the individual and
without understanding so you know
there's
uh
i've met so many interesting and
good-hearted and kind people who just
have
are lost
there's something in themselves that
just is discontented by the life that's
set up for them there's there's a whole
lot of
mental illness and trauma
and
my biggest thing i think for for people
who don't understand addiction is to
just understand not to take it
personally when it comes to to family
and
family members and loved ones uh
i could understand how how
my actions would would say
i don't love you and i don't care but
i don't think that's that that could be
further from the truth i think that
addicts uh
a lot of times care too much and maybe
uh
feelings a little too strong to handle
sometimes so they shut down and
yeah
it's not a not a very straightforward
disease we'll put it that way
yeah
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
um
most important thing i've learned
i'm not gonna say don't eat the yellow
snow
uh
it goes quick
so i've watched 15 years go by very
quickly and i'm i'm in the same position
i am now as i was 15 years ago
uh have i had a lot of life experiences
of a lot of met a lot of people gained a
lot of perspective and and understanding
about myself and others and i i believe
so but
it goes just just it goes quick uh
i think uh to be present to be present
and to be
um
i wish i'd have been present for the
last several years of my life
should be present
all right anthony thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck getting out
of here thank you
you